- So your youngest daughter
is almost four now,
and she's quite the dancer.
So everybody take a look at this.
- [Dwyane] What we got?
- [Kelly] I love this.
(crowd clapping)
Look, she is so focused.
- [Gabrielle] Focused.
- [Dwyane] She's serious.
- [Gabrielle] She's serious.
- [Kelly] She is focused.
This is my daughter at dance, by the way.
My daughter, yeah, she's so focused.
- [Dwyane] We give pep talks.
We give pep talks.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah, okay.
- [Dwyane] Before we go in-
- Are y'all those parents
like, "Baby, smile"?
Like, are you those, are you like-
- It's like when she look at me-
- [Kelly] Oh, you said-
- I just, you know, I just feel
like we put a lot of work in
and it's time to deliver.
You know?
- It's time to deliver.
- [Gabrielle] It's time to deliver.
Not unlike me, how I was at his games.
Where I was like, "Let's go three!
Let's go, three!
Come on, now!
Free throws are free for a reason.
Let's go!"
- [Kelly] Free for a reason.
- And so perhaps I'm
not the best dance mom.
- [Kelly] Oh my, God.
- I just say to Kaav, I
just say, "That's your mom."
Like, Kaav's trying to look
at me, cause mom is over here.
I'll be like, "Look at me, like at me."
- [Kelly] Look at me.
- Focus on me.
- Calm.
- [Dwyane] She's a little,
she's a little aggressive.
- She's excited.
- Yeah, she gets a little,
so Kaav focuses on dad.
- [Kelly] Yeah.